[Música]
el bayern munich ganó la champions
league una gran tristeza para los
seguidores del psg porque era la primera
vez que llegaban a la final una
competencia inédita que se celebró sin
público y en una sola sede por la
pandemia
crecen muertos dejo una estampida en
perú las personas intentaban escapar de
una fiesta clandestina tras la llegada
de la policía al lugar dado que el
encuentro violaba las restricciones por
la pandemia 22 personas fueron detenidas
y 15 dieron positivo al coronavirus
tenemos reporte desde el ima
al menos nueve muertos dejan la tormenta
tropical aura en haití y república
dominicana y a esta hora avanza hacia
cuba''
por su parte del huracán marco que se
encuentra en el golfo de méjico se
desplaza hacia el norte y se espera que
golpee la costa del estado de luisiana
este lunes
hola cómo están bienvenidos a las
noticias de quién france24 mi nombre es
alan austria empezamos en lisboa y es
que el bayern munich se ha consolidado
como el campeón de la champions league
2020 el equipo alemán venció 1 por 0 al
parís saint germain un evento sin
precedentes ya que por primera vez en la
historia se celebró en una sola sede y
sin público en el estadio para contener
la propagación del cob y 19 enlazamos
con guillermo post y analista deportivo
en buenos aires argentina es justo este
resultado pues valieron dar la impresión
de ser el mejor pero los alemanes
también sufrieron y tienen un gran
portero como podemos resumir en un
minuto un partido tan completo bueno
empezaste bien alan gracias buenas
noches gracias por convocar me es un
gran equipo se dio algo inédito ganó los
11 partidos que jugó en la champions
nunca había pasado tiene un gran arquero
lo había hecho muy bien contra lyon y lo
hizo muy bien hoy y en eso se puede
explicar el éxito de un equipo que
mereció ganar sobre todo porque después
del gol de 15 y coma que fue un golazo
un gran una gran jugada colectiva que
rubrica lo que es este equipo justamente
un equipo después de ese cabezazo puso
el control del partido no hubo chances
para neymar no hubo chances para empate
y to hell' tomó la decisión de quitar a
di maria que quizás era el mejor
atacante del equipo y por eso me da la
impresión de que el bayern munich ganó
su sexta con mucha justicia me dieron
esta cifra de la conoces 33 triunfos en
36 encuentros del bayern es el equipo
alemana el rival a vencer de esta
generación y qué pasa con los equipos
españoles en los últimos tiempos en la
champions ni real madrid ni atlético de
madrid ni barcelona ni valencia han
llegado
de cuartos de final si el real madrid se
tomó respiro después de haber ganado
tres champions con zinedine zidane se
tomó un respiro y esta vez cayó temprano
cayó muy temprano te diría y es cierto
que el bayern no es un equipo clásico
enorme pero que no has no suele hacer
ruidosas contrataciones como quizás sí y
su rival de hoy en pared es el germen o
los equipos de la liga o el manchester
city pero siempre sostiene una
estructura mantiene una previsibilidad y
acierta en las contrataciones hoy vimos
alfonso davis un chico de 19 años que
venía de jugar en la m ls lo hizo muy
bien en toda la experiencia de lisboa
tiene siempre las certezas de que va a
rendir bien ahora le sumó la posibilidad
de ganar y lo hizo de manera invicta y
eso es inédito pero marca también sus
fortalezas no olvidemos que le ganó 8 a
2 al barcelona le dejó una crisis
tremenda que tendrá que ordenar kumán
pero es cierto que los equipos alemanes
son particularmente este equipo alemán
hoy está
un paso por encima en estructura equipo
que la mayoría de los equipos de españa
muy bien guillermo poggi analista
deportivo en buenos aires argentina por
esta comunicación y toda análisis
completo en el tema deportivo y vamos
ahora a otros temas y es que una fiesta
en perú terminó en tragedia al menos 13
personas murieron y seis resultaron
heridas en una estampida humana
originada cuando la policía llegó a un
local de lima en el que decenas de
personas estaban reunidas a pesar de las
restricciones vigentes para luchar
contra la pandemia de los fallecidos 11
dieron positivo al coronavirus nos
ampliaba a nuestro corresponsal en la
capital francisco zacarías
13 personas murieron que al intentar
escapar a una intervención policial en
una discoteca al norte del iba a pesar
de estar prohibidas las reuniones
sociales vecinos del lugar alertaron a
las autoridades sobre la realización de
la fiesta clandestina la policía
intervino local los asistentes en su
mayoría jóvenes trataron de escapar por
una puerta para no ser retenidos pero
esta puerta se convirtió en una trampa
porque se abre hacia dentro y al hacerlo
bloquearon la vía en la desesperación se
aglomeraron ejercieron presión entre
ellos algunos cayeron al suelo isaf
hicieron la policía detuvo a 22 jóvenes
las autoridades sanitarias les
practicaron una prueba de descarte del
cob en 1915 los intervenidos dieron
positivo al coronavirus el presidente de
martín vizcarra expresó su indignación y
exigió a la justicia una rigurosa
investigación y la máxima sanción para
los responsables que organizaron la
fiesta clandestina que reunió a 120
personas el mandatario señaló que el
esfuerzo de la lucha contra la pandemia
se puede ir por la borda si no se
obedecen las medidas sanitarias pero se
aproxima a los 600 mil contagiados
porque hoy 19 es el segundo país de
américa latina y el pse
en el mundo con más casos de coronavirus
india superó los 3 millones de contagios
de kobe 19 siendo el tercer país del
mundo más afectado por el coronavirus y
una de las naciones donde más rápido se
está propagando esta pandemia y pese a
la alta curva de contagios
las autoridades celebra la alta tasa de
recuperación y el récord de un millón de
pruebas realizadas durante este fin de
semana marina sardenya nos amplía en el
siguiente informe
el coronavirus se está moviendo como una
gran ola a través de india en apenas dos
semanas se ha registrado más de un
millón de contagios siendo el tercer
país del mundo más golpeado por la
pandemia con más de tres millones de
positivos pese a estas cifras las
autoridades han abierto varios sectores
en un intento por reactivar su economía
estoy muy asustado tengo miedo de salir
miedo de ir a la oficina en mi caso mi
madre es una anciana de unos 67 años mi
esposa está embarazada
la razón de la propagación de ese virus
es la gente si la gente fuera más
civilizada o educada no se habría
extendido tanto mientras las tasas de
contagio se estabilizan en las grandes
ciudades como nueva delhi la capital o
en el centro financiero mumbai la
enfermedad avanza a gran velocidad en
las zonas rurales empobrecidas del norte
del país y entre las poblaciones más
ricas pero más mayores del sur de la
nación de más de 1300 millones de
habitantes
algunas áreas se están ganando control
como las grandes ciudades donde todo
comenzó pero en los pueblos más pequeños
las aldeas y gran parte del este de
india que no fue afectada
al inicio ahora están siendo golpeadas
este fin de semana india alcanzó el
récord de un millón de pruebas de kobe
19 el gobierno de narendra modi decretó
a principios de mes la entrada en la
tercera fase de eliminación progresiva
de las restricciones en buena parte del
país que cuenta con una de las
cuarentenas más estrictas del mundo
y volvemos al continente americano y es
que cuba se encuentra en alerta por la
tormenta tropical laura que ya deja al
menos nueve víctimas mortales tras su
paso por haití y república dominicana el
fenómeno provocó inundaciones y cientos
de viviendas colapsadas por su parte el
huracán marco que se encuentra en el
golfo de méjico se desplaza hacia el
norte y se espera que golpee la costa
del estado de luisiana este lunes vamos
a este informe de valentina datos
recientes
laura causó devastación a su paso por
república dominicana se estima que al
menos tres personas perdieron la vida en
medio del paso de la tormenta tropical
que causó el colapso de numerosas
viviendas precisamente en una de ellas
fallecieron una madre de su hijo
encima de una vez aparecer
los sueños de esta madre de éste sólo
tiene que dar la cara
sabía que está parada
porque lo que vivían por aquí no son
animales
laura también dejó numerosos sectores
inundados y alrededor de un millón de
personas sin electricidad
en haití al menos cinco personas
murieron y las intensas lluvias dejaron
las que son consideradas las peores
inundaciones que ha vivido el país en
años cuando vimos que el agua desbordada
se acercaba les pedimos que salieran
pero el agua inundó las casas y los mató
según los reportes preliminares se
estima que unas 2 millones de personas
quedaron afectadas tras el paso de la
tormenta tropical
ahora golpea a cuba donde miles de
ciudadanos han sido evacuados trasladar
nuestras cosas más importantes que
tenemos porque lo fundamental es salvar
la vida y bueno por lo menos los equipos
principalmente de acuerdo con el centro
nacional de huracanes la tormenta tocará
la costa de luisiana en la noche del
martes pero los efectos empezarán a
sentirse desde el lunes en la mañana
entretanto la región también se prepara
para recibir al huracán marco que se
encuentra en el golfo de mexico y se
prevé que afecte las costas de luisiana
y misisipí desde la mañana del lunes
llegamos al final de esta emisión les
agradecemos mucho su compañía los
invitamos a seguir con las noticias en
france 24 y cuídense cuídense mucho del
hobbit 19
[Música]